[Music]
instead of that's my main gig
that's that's that's sort of always what
i wanted to do
have you had any conversations with uh
mark ruffalo who's also in your category
and the internet's kind of going crazy
that wolverine and the hulk
are up against each other once again
i tried to reach out to him he's not
taking my calls so i guess
i'm somehow laying the track for another
feud here which thank goodness
we're not in the same room together i
mean that drag down i'm fighting
on camera actually i think i'm laughing
because
mark's a very good friend of mine and i
actually haven't spoken to him about it
um he's absolutely astonishing
in his i mean i think he's just one of
the best actors
of certainly of our generation has you
know always has been so
but wolverine would beat him for sure
let's just be very clear
well he's going to pause absolutely yeah
for sure it just
it just knocked he he would literally
cut him off at the knees
i didn't i don't know if you know this
but uh maybe that
the wolverine actually appeared first in
a whole comic
he was like uh last page
some guy coming so it was the hulk
series that he appeared and so that's
where that sort of feud came from
and then wolverine sort of really took
on this whole life so yeah i'm sure the
hulk is very jealous
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new marvel wolverine
video as you see hugh jackman there
talking about hulk versus wolverine
movies
so we'll break it down there's a bunch
of funny easter eggs in there i love
that he knows his history too he knows
all about wolverine and hulk's history
in the comics
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we'll do
a new amazon giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and let me
know where
you want them to introduce the new
version of the wolverine in the marvel
cinematic universe movies
the really cool thing about all this is
that mark ruffalo has actually been
working on getting some hulk
vs wolverine stuff going in the mcu i'll
just number these as we go along
starting with the really big stuff first
number five
so hugh jackman being interviewed here
for some upcoming awards where he's
competing against mark ruffalo for their
recent work
it is cool to know that they're friends
in real life even though they're rivals
in this sense
and they talk about the rivalry between
the hulk and wolverine in the comics
and the upcoming rivalry in future
marvel phase 4 marvel phase 5 movies
since marvel got all those x-men
characters back they can do a more comic
book
authentic backstory for the new version
of wolverine the mcu
fox could do all the weapon x stuff but
they could never do any of the hulk or
avengers captain america weapons plus
related stuff so you're missing a huge
part of wolverine's origin story so the
interviewer asks him if he's ever got
into it with mark ruffalo as friends
about hulk versus wolverine and he goes
on to joke about who would actually win
in that fight like wolverine would win
hands down of course hugh jackman is
going to say that wolverine would win
and he has
won many times in the past just think of
old man logan when he let himself get
eaten
by the older twisted version of the hulk
and just clawed his way out
and even though hugh jackman admitted
that when he originally took the role as
wolverine he didn't know
anything about wolverines in real life
he didn't think it was a real animal
and he didn't know anything about his
comic book origin but over the years he
eventually learned all that stuff and
now he knows about hulk's connection to
wolverine's original debut in the comics
so number four the story that he's
talking about during that clip wolverine
showing up as the shadowy figure
revealed at the end of an incredible
whole comic book
is actually from incredible hulk number
180 he had been dispatched by the us
government and the canadian government
to take down the incredible hulk who had
crossed over the border into canada it
was just on this big rampage
then in the next issue incredible hulk
number 181 that's where you actually
full-on see wolverine for the first time
in his costume and they beat the crap
out of each other
and it becomes the beginning of a
long-running rivalry between the two of
them with them having a bunch of
rematches in different comics through
the years
then what happened after that original
debut in the incredible hulk comic book
is eventually marvel created more of a
backstory for wolverine because he
became a super popular character like
hugh jackman says the character kind of
went on to have his own life
they reckoned in all the weapon x stuff
and then later they also tweaked that a
little more to introduce the concept of
the weapons plus program
which tied wolverine's origins way back
to captain america's origin
in the super soldier program in the
1940s so it's all about connecting
wolverine's origin story to pre-existing
avengers character origins
in number three if you haven't seen it
they've actually already adapted the
original hulk vs wolverine fight from
incredible hulk 181
to an animated movie it's a really short
movie it's just called hulk vs wolverine
it's exactly what it sounds like
obviously most of us want kevin feige
and marvel to get to something similar
in the mcu movies eventually
they've actually been working up to that
moment for longer than you think
there are actually a bunch of wolverine
easter eggs and references connecting
him to mcu hulk going all the way back
to the marvel phase 1 movies like the
incredible hulk movie in captain america
the first avenger movie with chris evans
the incredible hulk easter egg is a
little more relevant to what's happening
during marvel phase 4 with the new
movies in the disney plus series like
falcon and winter soldier but it's just
a continuation of more easter eggs from
captain america the first avenger
so you can kind of see that kevin feige
has been trying to lay the track work
for wolverine and the mcu for a
long long time 10 plus years almost
during captain america the first avenger
they do the captain america origin story
everybody knows it super soldier program
later in that movie because wolverine
james howlett was alive and fought
during world war
ii kevin feige said that he tried to get
a hugh jackman cameo in this captain
america scene of him rescuing all the
howling commandos
wolverine would not have been a howling
commando he would have just been another
regular soldier
trying to keep his mutant powers on the
dl obviously you can guess the reason
why he didn't actually show up in the
movie why that wound up not happening
because it was when fox was still
planning more wolverine spin-off movies
in the vein of wolverine origins
in the wolverine after that the number
two later in the incredible hulk movie
thunderbolt ross reveals to the
abomination that he himself
turned the original super soldier
program because it was a military
program
into the weapons plus program or it
evolved the program
continuing to work to try and enhance
u.s soldiers for combat that's the whole
point of the weapons plus
program the super soldier program bigger
better soldiers
he also revealed that he had been lying
to bruce banner who had been working for
him with his gamma research and the
purpose of his gamma research was
actually
part of the weapons plus program to make
bigger better soldiers
he was going to use that gamma research
in combination with the diluted form of
the super soldier serum that he was
pulling out of those cryo tanks
dr reinstein that you see on the label
here that's actually the
true name of dr erskine the person who
created the original super soldier serum
and gave it to captain america
that doesn't necessarily make the hulk
one of the weapons plus but you could
argue that he kind of is one
because he accidentally got his powers
during the weapons plus program
we all know wolverine is called weapon x
but the x actually stands for roman
numeral 10. he's the 10th
version of the weapons plus program the
reason why he was created in canada
is because the canadians became a lesser
part of the later weapons plus
experiments
but because the mcu tries to simplify a
lot of characters backstories just to
make it easier to digest
the new version of wolverine and the new
version of the weapon x program in the
mcu
can be something that thunderbolt ross
is involved with in a much
bigger way during the falcon and winter
soldier series which hopefully we'll get
to see before the end of the year
a huge part of the plot is the weapons
plus program being reactivated
in falcon in winter soldier trying to
stop it like look at us agent here he
gets a version of that super soldier
serum and is part of the weapons plus
program
thunderbolt ross reactivates so that'll
just be the continuation of what you saw
during incredible hulk on the path to
weapon x
and while we're talking about weapon x
stuff that program weapons plus is also
the path to red hulk
thunderbolt ross in the thunderbolts
team the number one even though hugh
jackman has said that he's kind of
retired from being wolverine and doesn't
plan on doing a ton more movies
mark ruffalo has said that he's actually
talked to marvel about doing a hulk vs
wolverine project
he's been pitching kevin feige on new
movies and incredible hulk revival
disney plus series
the one thing that makes it harder for
them to do a hulk vs wolverine legit
movie
is because universal still holds part of
the rights to the hulk
characters so they can't really do a
hulk solo movie again
yet but they can do a thor ragnarok
style crossover movie with a ton of hulk
in it and even though it sounds weird
they can't put hulk
in the title of a movie right now the
rules and right situation is kind of
strange but eventually marvel will work
all that stuff out so i think that by
the time they're actually ready
to make a new wolverine movie that
really won't be an issue anymore
the next place that mark ruffalo's bruce
banner hulk is supposed to show up is on
the she-hulk series
as part of her origin he didn't say how
many episodes he'd be in but they're
actually working out that new contract
for him right now
but let me know in the comments do you
think that marvel will do hulk versus
wolverine in an upcoming avengers movie
like avengers 6 or do you think that
they'll try and save that for its own
movie or disney plus series
congratulations von doom you're the
giveaway winner from my last big new
mutants movie review
please email me on the about page of my
channel so i can get your contact
details
in sadder news you all probably saw that
chadwick boseman recently passed away
there's a special that disney and marvel
are doing on abc tonight
i don't really know what the content of
that's going to be but i might make a
video for it next week
i've already done a tribute video for
chadwick boseman you can click here to
watch that
may he rest in power and you can click
here for my marvel
new mutants movie review thank you so
much for watching everyone stay safe
i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you